témoin les choses vraies bombes non les
vols étaient morts
c'est la troisième fois ce mois-ci que
je lui fasse ça c'est à vous de voir si
vous la mère du roi qu'est que tu as à
faire dans la vie quand elle cherche un
commissariat ne peut pas continuer comme
ça tu finiras comme moi ce sera plutôt
crever pourquoi tu vois la loose je vous
présente ma demoiselle cerise qui nous
vient directement de paris
comme vous pouvez le constater justement
tout comme ça tourne en ce moment je
bâtis si tu fumes affiche entre deux
états il m'a draguée qui comme une merde
qu'est ce que je viens de dire
lénine tu sais qui c'est un chanteur de
rue brésilien
ni vin de riz se disent tu kiffes ma
colère
christophe klouchi aux fonctions
que s'ils font tous ces gens il veut
changer de chambre
démocratie pour tous